[Music]
I think I can I think I can I think I
can I think I can and over the mountain
little engine went we're gonna get over
that mountain Governor Jerry Brown
championed a high-speed rail that would
connect southern and northern California
despite cost overruns lawsuits over land
use and a lack of private investment now
that high-speed rail plan is being
scaled back by new governor Gavin Newsom
current project as planned would cost
too much and respectfully take too long
what Gavin Newsom has done is he's
spittin jerry brown's i Newsome
basically said Jerry this is your little
choo-choo and I can't afford to pay for
your dream columnist and fellow at
Chapman University Joel cockin has been
skeptical of California's high-speed
rail for years and says the only reason
Brown stuck with it was because it
offered him a chance to have some sort
of physical legacy Jerry Brown was the
only reason why this thing hadn't been
killed before Gavin Newsom is looking at
the future and saying you know we're
gonna have all sorts of fiscal issues
they're all things we want to do and
this is an absurdity and high-speed rail
will now only stretch from Bakersfield
to Merced that's not gonna be easy
because there's just not a lot of money
to be made between Bakersfield we're set
you know this is the ultimate train to
nowhere going from two places that don't
have any particular relationship with
each other it's a part of the of the
state where people actually drive the
vast majority of people drive by time
got the station you still have to drive
it's not like going from a place where
people live because they can afford to
to a job center there's no job center
involved here and here's the thing that
really bothers me the Central Valley has
very serious economic problems there is
huge degrees of poverty unemployment
some of the poorest parts of the United
States are in the Central Valley and
we're doing this kind of fancy choo-choo
he says the high-speed rail was always a
solution in search of a problem
the problems in California are not
getting from LA or Orange County to San
Jose or San Francisco Southwest does a
spectacularly good job we have all
these regional airports most people in
the in the major population centers are
15 20 minutes maybe a half hour away
from an airport where they can go in an
hour
directly to where they want to go the
problems in California are inside the
state it's getting from one part of
Southern California to another it's a
problem of getting from one part of the
Bay Area to another and this didn't
address that at all everything from the
Great Society to the New Deal started
with a vision for our future green New
Deal backers say they want more
high-speed train as a way to replace air
travel and add green jobs this is a shot
across the bow for the green New Deal
the green new deal is is based on you
know some ideas of people that you ever
wonder if they ever actually realized
how big the United States is you know
when people say we could be just like
Europe or Europe is much smaller the
distances between cities are much less
the cities were built in many cases two
three four hundred years ago sometimes
more and they were built around trains
to start with even so eighty percent of
the people in Europe drive to work so
the idea that you would go to a country
where ninety ninety-five percent of the
people drive to work and that you were
going to replace the roads or that most
of the long distance travel the vast
majority of it takes place in the
airplanes it is just lunacy I think that
some of these people like AOC I think
somebody ought to put him in a car and
say let's strive to Nebraska and let's
see how practical a train would be to
get to Omaha it's not very practical at
all
so what's Newsom dueling here he's
basically scaling back he's buying time
to try to save money and hopefully get
more money to get it going again
the real battle in the Democratic Party
is between reality and fantasy and this
was a big win for reality people knew
that this was an incredibly stupid
boondoggle and of course what's really
going to be interesting is is any other
state going to be as stupid as we are
you